[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to Austria ladies and gentlemen
a very warm welcome to the 2019 European
inventor award here in Vienna and a
special welcome to all of you watching
our live stream or on several state foul
or on science AV my name is Fernando to
barrini and I'm delighted to welcome you
all to Austria's magnificent capital for
centuries the beating heart of a
multi-ethnic multilingual Empire and
even today host to numerous
international institutions and UN
agencies Vienna is highly rated for its
innovation culture urban planning and
quality of life and here by the
beautiful Danube we can appreciate why
Vienna has been the home to a dazzling
array of creative geniuses over the
years from composers like Mozart Haydn
mala and Strauss to painters like Klimt
and Honda Vasa to philosophers like Ben
Stein and papa and to scientists like
Boltzmann Schrodinger and ZEB advice and
let us not forget the celebrated
Viennese cuisine from tar fish bits to
Venus schnitzel from apfelstrudel
to marilyn noodle from pallet chicken to
of course the Saha Tata invented here in
1832 by France Safa whose son Edward
went on to found there's a hotel on the
strength of the cakes reputation I'm not
making you hungry am i I only meant to
whet your appetite for inventors and
inventions so let's start with a show
I'd like to welcome all their
excellencies and all the finalists who
have joined us here today as well as all
of you ladies and gentlemen our
distinguished guests and I'd like to
extend a very special welcome to our
gracious host the president of the
European Patent Office mr. Antonio
Gambino's please come on stage to start
the 2019 European
venture Wars
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
distinguished guests ladies and
gentlemen a very warm welcome to
everyone here and to all those watching
online and on TV we are delighted you
could join us for what is the 14th
edition of this European inventor award
and for an event that has become one of
the highlights in the innovation
calendar each year it attracts more and
more public attention and 2019 has been
no exception
in the last few months videos of our
inventors have received over 13 million
views on social media which is
[Applause]
which is a great testament to the
finalists and their work I want to start
by thanking everyone who has played my
role in this inventor award and that
begins with recognizing the work of all
our examiner's and formality offices and
everyone who supports them throughout
the many departments of the EPO not
forgetting the words of appeal they are
the ones we need to thank for the
patents and services our innovators rely
on and without their efforts we simply
wouldn't be in a position to all this
award today there are also lots of
people at EPO who've played a part
specifically in organising this event I
don't have time to list them all now but
I hope they know who they are and that
we are very grateful for everything
you've done to make this event a success
but no matter no matter what we do at
EPO we couldn't all the seminal ceremony
without the help of many others outside
the office our member states user
associations colleagues from throughout
the innovation community and members of
the public have all put forward
inventions inventors resulting in over
470 exceptional proposals and it goes
without saying we are very grateful for
the work of our international jury which
has given us fifteen brilliant finalists
thank you all for donating your time and
expertise I think they deserve a big
round of applause
this work and the work of everyone
involved is helping us to shine a light
on innovation and some truly outstanding
inventors when I was learning about
their inventions and what they've
accomplished I was struck with a sense
of purpose by the way they set out in a
mission and we simply cannot
underestimate the importance of that
work because those endeavors are having
a huge impact on our lives their
innovations generate great benefits for
our economy they create jobs contribute
to higher wages and increase our GDP and
exports but it's far from being about
financial gain it's cleared inventors
here today set out to make a world a
brighter place safer smarter more
sustainable some of them took on the
challenge of combating deadly diseases
others have discovered new methods to
mitigate our environmental impact then
there are advances in agricultural
technology efforts to kick-start global
connectivity and the emergence of a new
safer era in Road Transport and whatever
the field they all changing our
understanding of what we thought
possible and they are advancing the
frontiers of science as Archimedes of
Syracuse said give me a lever and a
place to stand
I'll move the herd and that is exactly
what our finalists have done today we
want to fulfill part of our mission in
telling you more about their
achievements to tell the stories of
these men and women who are making great
strides in innovation science and
research stories of perseverance stories
of ingenuity and ultimately stories of
what we believe are great contributions
to our society
I am sure that by the time this event
finishes you
we'll also have a deep appreciation of
our their work is leading to a better
world for all of us
so I will finish by saying whoever is
selected as the winner in each category
they all deserve our respect and
admiration just to be selected as a
finalist is already a great achievement
we wish you the very best of luck and I
hope we will all enjoy this 14 edition
of the European inventor award thank you
very much
thank you very much with the Campinas
all our finalists are brilliant
scientists and engineers advancing human
knowledge in their own fields with their
breakthroughs their inventions are
protected by European patents but have
you spared a thought for how their
patents came to be granted now the
examiners of the European Patent Office
faced some mind-boggling paradoxes when
trying to assess if an alleged invention
really is new and deserving of a patent
so here are three examiners explaining
just how cunning they have to be
switching they're all looking for
something for some of us the thrill of
the hunt is our daily job seeking
finding discovering inventors are
searching too they search for inventions
they search for new markets they search
for investors and licenses and they come
to the PIO looking for high quality and
timely search results they need to know
that the invention is really unused and
deserving of a patent they rely on what
we find to base their important business
decisions to give them early certainty
TPO we have much better tools
and much better strategies for searching
through patents and technical records
from all over the world we search for
the patentability
of inventions
but any search for the novelty of an
invention is by its nature paradox so
here's the puzzle what a search or
reference that is believed not to exist
to be patentable any product a process
must never have been publicly disclosed
before the application was filed the
inventor is convinced that their
invention is new that there is nothing
quite like it anywhere in the world if
you examiner's are problem solvers first
and foremost we are all scientists and
engineers trained to think laterally to
decide upon the most relevant places to
search and we have digital access to
global collections of data including
over 50 million patent documents from
Japan China and Korea as well as
millions of standards documents how to
recognize the reference describing the
invention in a different context of
vocabulary
we got the right digital search Tucson
strategies to solve this puzzle too
no matter where a patent document has
been published and however described in
whatever language it will have been
classified according to technology type
the EPO has developed the world's most
refined classification system for
patents jointly with the US Patent and
Trademark Office and over 20 other
offices now use it too regardless of
language documents describing the same
technology will be classified using the
same term
and to help us understand documents from
everywhere patent translate works in 32
languages
and the final paradox if despite all
this data and all these tools no
relevant references are found how can we
tell the search is complete that's what
friends are for
we work together calling on the
expertise and knowledge of our
colleagues to leave no stone unturned
and when it comes to the important
decision as to whether or not to grant
or refuse a patent application it's
three of us who must agree search
exhaustively every day to ensure that
patents are granted only for new and
non-obvious inventions our solid
searches and written opinions are
transparent and reliable they are the
basis for robust European patents as
leader certainty in up to 44 countries
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the EPO has over 4,300 examiner's
detectives like Sherlock Holmes so now
you know they really are finding the
needle in the haystack every day so now
the time has come
ladies and gentlemen to discover who
will be taking home one of six trophies
today it's time to discover who the
winners are there are many prizes for
science or innovation but the European
inventor award is unique in celebrating
not only the inventors contribution to
scientific and technological progress
but also the benefits to society and the
economy improving our lives
and creating jobs our finalists come
from diverse backgrounds some working in
major companies others in their own
businesses they represent the great
variety of circumstances in which
innovation is nurtured
therefore the trophies will be presented
in the following categories industry
research non EPO country's small and
medium-sized enterprises and lifetime
achievement before we reach the last
category we will present a special
trophy to the inventor selected by you
the public in the popular prize let us
begin with the first category for
outstanding and successful inventors
whose inventions have been patented by
large European companies from the
Netherlands Alex and upon delay Lee and
Carol fondant bear
from spain antonio corridor morgue arrow
and carlos firm in melendez-diaz mr
corridor is here on behalf of the book
and from austria
klaus fighting uh and month it happens
and now let's learn about their
achievements but before let's hear what
the EPO examiners have to say about
their inventions they have 289 European
patents between them and developed an
entirely new way of dairy farming it's
big data meets agriculture it's very
tasty milk and it's very happy cow how
he can move freely in the bond as it can
be milked whenever he likes it
freedom of the cows was our highest
priority when we developed the milking
robot yeah and high-tech machine that
milks cows fully automatically 24/7
without human interaction also the
farmer enjoys the freedom he can plan
his day like he wants to do and this
means that next generations of farmers
also are more willing to join to do the
work on a farm
because system us not because the
astronaut is connected in a single quote
to the spaceship when he is free in
space and so is the teeth cup of the cow
connected to the Machine this court was
my first offensive at the beginning our
system was a little bit out of space for
the conventional farmers so to enter the
market at the beginning we licensed our
patents also to competitors the goal was
to have digital evolution in farming
quicker accepted by the marketplace and
it worked sometimes we joke that the
cows accept the robots thicker than the
farmer
it took us eight years to develop the
milking robot and thereafter ten years
to introduce it to the marketplace and
this also changed our company completely
we moved from a machine manufacturer to
a company focusing on robotics and data
we want to help farmers to create food
for us as consumers in ways that are
more profitable more enjoyable and more
sustainable while giving back to freedom
to the cows these are happy cows
[Music]
[Music]
there are two key aspects one is the
substantial reduction in constructional
costs up to 45% the other is the QB pods
potential to protect coastlines against
the effects of climate change some
inventions protect on a personal scale
but I work on a bigger scale weighs six
tons
but we need thousand of them traditional
breakwaters are easy to make with
regular cubes but they have one problem
through the action of the waves the
blocks slowly set and face to face which
can bump up
two reports have protrusions on its face
to prevent them in self patting
it ensures that there are always gaps to
absorb the waves anticipate energy
the safe was originally invented by the
Polytechnical University of balancing my
company in subtle license the patent to
try to find a way to realize this
special safe
our invention was a more efficient mode
the save hundreds of thousands of euros
in construction cost and it can be
opened it would be move is really a very
clever tool mr. Menendez was at this
time the foreman of the side with his
experience and my knowledge on design
calculation and structural resistance
our company Sato was granted an envelope
in patent for our mold
now horrible some people are better
protected when I started this job I
thought it was just work but now I see
how important my wall is for the people
living on the coast
[Applause]
thinking the other way rounds might be
the key in answering one of the most
difficult environmental questions what
do we do with plastic wastes these
inventors already have a solution
plastic is not a bad thing if we change
the way we handle plastic after use
circle economy as it is shown from the
paper industry is the right way also for
the plastic industry our machine recycle
plastic into pellets
without any harm for the environment
these pellets are used afterwards to
produce new products for our daily life
in a mechanical recycling process we had
sometimes the special materials like
fibers in issue and we had no ideas how
we could solve this issue
the invention came out of 15 minutes
clever thinking there's a way around and
then I had it we changed the direction
of Socata vector is the opposite flow of
extrusion system this leads to a better
feeling and smoothes the feeling of
screw six leads to a higher performance
set ideas so simple
patented technology now is used in our
machines all over the world for high
output better quality and the process
the billet increase
for the economic success patterns play a
major role the patent is an inspiration
the source for new ideas you can realize
our problems are solved by other people
and it gives you new concepts new ways
to solve you our mission is another life
for plastic because we care we only have
to change the direction change our
thinking change the handling of plastic
after use change to circle economy in
the plastic industry
[Music]
[Applause]
to present the award in the industry
category I'd like to invite on stage
miss Mariana Carrie pava president of
the Austrian Patent Office as well as
ambassador helmet iki legal advisor of
the Austrian Ministry of Europe
integration and Foreign Affairs please
come on stage
[Music]
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen the winner in the
category industry is
[Music]
Joseph a stinger and Munford Hachi
our first winner passed by Sting a month
ago big round of applause please come up
on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
if you don't mind I'd like to ask you a
few questions if you could step forward
a little bit yeah thank you very much
now first of all has the haircut -
that's yone I have a first question for
you mr. Hawkin so plastic pollution is
finally getting global attention now but
plastic recycled products are still high
unfairly regarded as inferior now can
public opinion be turned around I think
the public opinion has to be turned
around and I think we do not know how
many products we have already - tain our
hands with recycled products out of it
and we have to bring this to the people
to the right understanding it is
possible circle economy in the plastic
industry so your goal is to bring that
to the same level of acceptance as with
the paper industry now how will patterns
help you achieve this goal the pedants
is always good to be a one step ahead in
the technology because their recycling
industry is quite new and you have to
bring in new technology to solve that
now I have a question for fighting now
do you see the main role of your
machines being pellet factories or
performing waste management first of all
I must say thank you I'm really
emotional iced not so easy to answer I
think we are part of the game
and since we have to focus in the what
we have to see we can write motivate
even with such an event we can show
people play with us do and the plastic
industry is on the way that we realized
we are working now 24 26 years in this
business and dramatically things have
changed during the last four years so we
are part of the game and honestly it is
not really relevant if we are making
pellets or something whatever we play
with them and we bring up results and we
a chop on this rock yeah it's really
impressive now with new material
combinations constantly appearing in
products how does that push you to
become more innovative for sure reality
is designer are coming to new ideas
packaging whatever and so new solutions
must be found two handles is more
complicated with whatever materials and
I think this is possible and this
invention was a part of the game again
this helps us to produce complex
quantity out of complex more complicated
materials it's always you have some
obstacles to get to new inventions you
have to go on there's no time to to stay
so we have a lot to do in the future -
great thank you very much big round of
balls again would you please step over
for the photographs
[Music]
please face this way oh this
photographer our heroes of the circular
economy with 37 grams of European
patents between them and it's
astonishing to think how the 6000 ARIMA
systems around the world produce 14.5
million tons of plastic pellets every
year ready to make new products
all right please we take your seats the
winners of the industry category
perfecting and Munt beard puppy
[Applause]
without further ado we will now move on
to the second category research honoring
pioneering inventors who work at
universities or research institutions
this is finalists are from France
Jerome Gannon
from Germany Matias Mun
and from Italy Patrizia Pelini Brescia
now let's take a look at their
inventions and before we're gonna hear
again some epi examiners and see what
they have to say about them
this invention is a game-changer because
the key to saving millions of lives is
to have a proper and precise diagnosis
my lab here in Paris is actually in a
former cloister and these buildings were
protecting the monks and their gardens
our immune system is protecting us in a
very different way it's not static like
these old stones in fact it's very
dynamic well actually you know there are
more T cells in our body that there are
stars in the night sky
when I started working on cancer the
field of cancer was mostly about the
tumor cells but for me as an
immunologist it was absolutely obvious
that the immune system had to play a
role in cancer
thanks to my senior position at its erm
I was able to start this long and risky
project I knew it would take a long time
and involve a multidisciplinary team
[Music]
it's a completely new way of looking at
cancer patients we are now looking at
their immune system rather than looking
at their tumor cells a digital scanner
text images of all the tumor samples and
then our software is counting every
single t-cell then our software
calculates the immuno score of an
individual patient by knowing how active
is the immune system now we can predict
if a patient is at high risk or low risk
of recurrent cancer this enables doctors
not only to classify more precisely
cancerous but also to give the patient's
the most effective therapies without
over treating them immuno score is on
the way to become a new standard for
cancer classification
[Music]
[Applause]
as a patent examiner at the European
Patent Office I've been very fortunate
to discover incredible inventors that
break new ground
mattias man is definitely one of them
and maybe one of the most brilliant one
his invention is nowadays used in many
labs worldwide
the future is happening now by analyzing
the human proteome that is the set of
all the proteins you'll be able to
detect and diagnose diseases much better
than before
twenty years ago people thought it was
enough to study the genome of an
organism but the genome is largely fixed
at birth so it doesn't change over the
life course of an organism but now we
know that's really in the proteome where
all the action happens
like with these creatures they have the
same genome but very different proteomes
this key which tells you more about the
real shape of the organism
over the last 25 years I've been working
on methods to analyze the proteome
[Music]
what we do is we take the proteins from
the patients and we chop them up into
small pieces called peptides and those
peptides get separated on very fine
columns at the end of those columns
their electro sprayed and they're
brought into a mass spectrometer where
they're counted and identified by
fragmenting
for the qualification we'll use the
select method and this introduces a
subtle math shift by heavy isotopes and
with this we can perfectly quantify the
proteins
and use the clinical knowledge craft to
map them on to known diseases
we want this to reach the patient to
benefit the patient and for this we need
to interest industry and they need a
patent otherwise they won't invest
what we're hoping to develop with the
proteomics is like a powerful radar
where we can see precisely the disease
that the given patient has how they
should be treated and whether the
treatments in effect so instead of
flying blind we flying with a very
powerful radar
our dream is that this will be the
future of Medicine
[Music]
a scientist working the field of cancer
early detection can be the Holy Grail to
save millions of lives more than 90% of
patients with cancer
died because of metastasis the cells
coming from invasive tumor circulating
in the blood to other organs if we could
detect those wandering tumor salsa
before metastasis occurred we could then
stop the process and save the patients
the challenge was detecting those
extremely rare circulating tumor cells
in 10 ml of blood which is the volume of
spoon we have 50 billion blood cells but
perhaps only one of you tumor cells this
is like finding one person out of the
population of seven planets Earth
we needed to find the right way to
pretreat the blood and the right
combinations of conditions to be able to
filter the blood and extract those rare
tumor cells in a very sensitive manner
and this is I said to bring this
invention to the patients we set up a
company and for this the patent was
absolutely essential it helped to raise
money and to serve our aim of saving
lives
our work just opened a window into a new
domain of medicine non-invasive and
predictive oncology when the time comes
for me to look back on my life I want to
be able to say that I did all what I
could to improve cancer patients lives
[Music]
to present the award in the research
category I would like to invite on stage
mr. Christian option boo executive
director of the European Union
intellectual property office
[Applause]
[Music]
and the winner in the of the European
inventor award 2019 in the catalyst
category research goes to say home
channel big applause winner in the
research category dr. Jim general please
come up on stage
[Applause]
felicitations don't now with hindsight
it seems quite obvious that measuring a
patient's immune response should be an
integral part of a doctor's assessment
of a Kansas development now why did it
take so long in your opinion to change
minds actually it's it it's changing
completely the field of cancer because
oncologist geneticists they were all
focusing on tumor cells and tumor cell
alteration so for long the immune system
was not considered to play any role for
cancer so it's been a long journey
because it's been hundreds of years that
we are trying to demonstrate that the
immune system is indeed playing a major
role which was what we could basically
do with the aminos call and now that
they are immune or therapies that are so
efficient that are basically reboost in
our immune system now we see that we can
save patients life so it's a real
complete challenge in cancer now yeah
now in your team there are many
different people with many different
skills how important was the
multidisciplinary approach in creating
immune score essential because we
applied new technologies we apply a
throughput methods we needed by
informaticians we needed
biostatisticians we needed of course all
the clinicians immunologist so yeah
research cannot be done alone so it's
very important to have very expert
people in many different disciplines to
be able to tackle and demonstrate new
findings yeah and what roles have
patents played in developing invention
for the development of the invention
which a it's more father the next step
that is the creation of the company to
have investors you know really believing
that they are protected so for investors
is very important and so we could create
the company because we had those
patterns now oncologists around the
world is set to adopt the amino score is
the benchmark test for colon cancer is
this just the beginning I think it's at
the beginning yes we we had this huge
international validation first on colon
cancer but we already have multiple data
on multiple other care
two types so we know that this is also
very active and very essential for many
many cancer types the immune system
basically is working for any type of
tumors yeah all right thank you very
much congratulations again big round of
applause please step over here
[ __ ]
the amino score is giving clinicians far
better insights into the progress of
cancers and therefore treatment options
it's a real game-changer and his
improved cancer prognosis he's well on
the way becoming the new global standard
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen as we have already
seen two of these beautiful trophies let
me explain that the design for the
trophies is refreshed every year this
year we have been inspired by an
important economic resource from Austria
our film will explain more we hope you
will enjoy it innovations transform our
world to reflect this the trophies
redesigned every year
the basic form of the sale symbol for
human ingenuity remains the same but
materials and manufacturing technologies
change
[Music]
this makes the trophy for the European
inventor what an ingenious work of art
itself
in the past we use diverse materials
like porcelain Portuguese azulejos
in Asian class 3d printing
this year the trophies made from wood
one of the oldest construction materials
it has been used to fashion tools
structures furniture and ornaments for
millennia in every human society
trees not only keep the ecosystem
balanced transform a co2 into oxygen
they also play a major role in the
economy of Austria
[Music]
the trophy this year shows perfectly our
technology how to produce lightweight
structures with a traditional and
sustainable material with wood our
present wooden 3d chipping technology
starts on a computer means we used to
policy optimization to calculate the
inner structure and then we have maximum
stiffness and maximum strength
for each category we choose different
types of food all native to Europe
[Music]
the production process starts with human
brain press we use this machine for
pressing very thin layers of wood in a
specific shape after this first step we
have the perfect fiber orientation for
the latest structure to have a
lightweight object to Miller out and
leave here some struts to have a stiff
and stable structure
because of the very complex shape of the
trophy we have to produce them in two
parts the front and the back those parts
will clue together enough that we finish
it and building craving with the laser
after one day of production for each
sale the trophies are ready to honor the
most genius and creative minds of our
time at ceremony in Vienna
[Music]
Wow aren't they impressive and amazing
to learn that even today wood can be
engineered in innovative ways I'm sure
you know even more curious to find out
who will receive the next one the EPO
serves innovators from all over the
world they received a hundred and
seventy five thousand applications last
year but just over half of these came
from inventors outside of your own so
now we're very pleased to introduce some
of the most astonishing inventors from
countries which are not one of the EPO
s38
member states the nominees are from
Israel Amnon choix and the mobile eye
team represented today by team member
kitty on Steam
from Japan Akira Yoshino
and from the USA heaven buyer and Gavin
McIntyre
now let's take a look at their
inventions thanks to one invention over
30 million cars worldwide are safer to
drive saving millions of lives
[Music]
how can we engineers save lives by
enabling cars to see the system sees
what the driver sees it sees the road
ahead vehicles pedestrians lane markings
traffic signs traffic lights
[Music]
at the time I experienced clear interest
from the industry for a driving
assistant system they thought they
needed radars laser rangefinders stereo
camera systems all these complicated
systems coming from the field of
computer vision and artificial
intelligence we understood that we can
make this work with a single camera by
that reducing cost make the system work
better and as a result have it on every
car
so this is the basic system so we have
here the camera sensor and the lens so
this is the camera part and then this is
our IQ processor on the board and this
is the complete system it does
everything
there are two applications one is
headway monitoring keeping a safe
distance from the vehicle ahead there we
need to measure the distance and we use
perspective we look for the bottom of
the target being the vehicle or the
pedestrian the bottom of the target in
the image and the distance from the
horizon it's a bit more complicated than
that but that's the basic idea the
second application is working out the
time to collision and there we look at
the expansion of the targets in the
image and that tells us something about
when we are going to collide
[Music]
we were really formed in a garage but
through a series of inventions we were
ahead of everyone else we filed patents
to improve the technology and today
we're over 1,000 employees most global
car manufacturers have chosen our
driving assistance system
our goal is vision zero eliminating the
human factor behind traffic accidents
and traffic fatalities we're out there
today we are in cars today and we are
saving lives today
[Applause]
none of us can deny the global impact of
this invention some five billion people
are using it every day everywhere maíam
battery has changed the world powers our
modern society I feel very honored to
see my invention in everybody's hand
before doing research I always try to
consider what the world really means
in the 1980s portable devices came in
fashion entertain alter detachable
batteries they are heavy and limited to
1.5 both
I invented the combination of Raheem
cobalt oxide castle with carbon anode I
developed a new organic electrode and a
new electrode configuration using metal
foil
the additional ions just go back and
forth between cathode and anode without
any chemical reaction so the battery can
be recharged many times
I developed the separator membrane that
smells if the battery gets too for
acting like a fuse my invention have led
to many patents for Asahi tossing the
patents are not used to keep people out
thus we license our person to encourage
many of the manufacturers to use our
technology I have been defining
batteries for over 40 years
my latest innovations are Co batteries
for electric vehicle under date I hoped
we changed the world
[Music]
buttons are often crucial for startups
and SMEs particularly in this case
they've honed in on a new domain in
material science it is based on strong
ecological roots and has a potential to
branch in many directions during the
final year of our mechanical engineering
studies we took a course called inventor
studio which had three goals develop a
technology they could have a sustainable
impact on the planet and fend something
that could be patented and start a
company that's exactly what Evan and I
did
[Music]
I grew up on a farm where I learned the
importance of valuing the earth
we've been looking for a solution to
single-use plastics when we stumbled
upon mozillian and it's what you'd find
if you were to look beneath a mushroom
and it's these billions and billions of
tiny little fibers and you can kind of
think of it as one of nature's
biopolymers or plastics mycelium is a
natural adhesive it grows on and binds
particles together we thought that's it
we can use mozillian to grow
replacements for plastics
our process begins with locally sourced
agricultural waste which we mix together
with trace amounts of mycelium over the
course of just four days the mycelium
grows transforming that waste into a
product which we then dry render it
inactive and it's ready for shipment
so what can you do with my cilia
materials you can grow protective
packaging materials that have really
unique performance attributes they have
high strength foam compost ability and
are grown was just a fraction of the
energy you started here because
single-use plastics are rapidly becoming
a worldwide problem both inside of our
cities as well as bio accumulating in
our forests and oceans
[Music]
our patent portfolio has been incredibly
important for us as a technology
provider and allowing us to license our
technology internationally to extend our
footprint beyond just upstate New York
from inventor studio our business has
continued to grow very similar to my
psyllium our mission is to grow better
materials that are compatible with
planet Earth and patents have helped our
growth to
[Applause]
to present the award in the non EPO
country's category I would like to
invite on stage mr. Bernardo Khalsa dia
Sarmiento director of the department of
trade investment and innovation at the
United Nations industrial development
organization who need o
[Music]
[Applause]
the European inventor award 2019 in the
category non EPO goes to Yoshino this
category Yoshino please come on stage
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we have a live translator
yoshino Hakka say omedetou gozaimasu get
into the light
thank you now a battery that can be
recharged again and again and again now
that used to be the stuff of science
fiction it was unthinkable before you
invention how did that breakthrough make
you feel when it actually happened do
you remember dainty no Bible study aid
akuto during sticky mustard a Nazi or a
lot de Malmaison can keep Ricky Ricardo
can expand ties nicely
- EDTA on the internal duty mr. Kinney
day not that authoritative Gianni
Infantino cockiness well the most
important thing with the battery is once
it's charged that that charge level
should maintain and when I first saw it
with my decision Ian's battery that it
really stayed on a stable level and that
was when I knew that I've succeeded it
and that was wonderful great so just
imagine
like you've stayed in this field since
the 1980s creating new inventions now
what was your motivation to stay in that
same field how did you and I think the
Coke machine data - in one word
curiosity that's a very good quality for
an inventor
[Applause]
now patterns have allowed you to keep
focusing on research and development by
licensing the pattern doubt to battery
manufacturers was that a conscious
decision
Thank You Caillou - you can thank you
Casa Monica dc1 focus author good news
for the cricketer in speaking at it it
will take another so definite an amoeba
or cannot you are DT me on date dainty
no market no he'll get a tummy security
license ish the whole I need a lot doc
you gotta - the the reason the decision
was to actively license my patents in
order to expand the market establish and
expand the market to make it to
popularize it and that was my decision
mmm-hmm now how soon do you think that
all road vehicles will be
battery-powered and what do you think of
the barriers that keep us from reaching
this goal
oh no you guys hired Thomas insane
Sanjana Denis in San Giovanni Atari you
know oh dang he doesn't care to my
message
I reckon that it would be quite soon say
by 2030 2035 I think a lows of cars will
run only EP electric vehicle and and
what will be the barriers that what does
he think
Kakinada Kaja total dainty no-cost
option in the candy bomber
it kind of you then they got a hospital
car tin Sok ocarina mondays
I cannot attain mechanically
autonomously but two biggest issues at
the moment is the cost of the battery
itself and the second one is the the
running distance how far the coverage
how far you last
well I'm sure with your inventions we're
gonna get there eventually
congratulations again please they're
going in for the pictures
dr. Nikita Yoshino he just never stopped
invention after invention after
invention for decades to give us the
battery that we all rely on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
please retain the seeds
it is often said that small and
medium-sized enterprises are the engine
of innovation in Europe so let us now
continue by honoring inventors from this
vital and dynamic sector of the economy
the nominees in this category are from
Norway as Ben Beck
from the United Kingdom Richard Palmer
and Philip green
and from the Netherlands Rick Pryor
and now let's take a look at their
achievements as Ben Beck's
invention is remarkable because it uses
a science fiction solution to address a
problem that is just 15 millimeters big
however causes an economical damage of
more than 1 billion euros annually just
a single industry in just a single
country here we can see a lot of salmon
swimming by our lasers having their
lives removed they keep coming back and
back all the time so they'd probably
like it
[Music]
the total cost of fighting sea lice in
Norway is between 1 to 1.5 billion euros
each year
optical delousing which is my invention
solves this sea lice problem without
having to use any chemicals and it also
provides better fish welfare our system
uses stereo cameras a powerful laser
source and very fast mirrors to direct a
laser beam and once our software
recognizes a sea lice on a salmon
swimming by we shoot it with the laser
we only have a few milliseconds we are
using our own algorithms neural networks
and artificial intelligence to recognize
the sea lice
back in 2008 2009 my engineering company
started to note the effects of the
financial crisis being a supplier to the
oil and gas industry was not easy at
that time and I decided to look for
other businesses I cannot tell you where
the idea came from it just came out of
the blue once I learned about the sea
lice we went to the local store and
bought a salman and we tried to stick
the sea lice on to the salman and we had
a borrowed laser that we fired on the
sea lice and we saw that the lice was
killed and then we knew we got something
here
as an inventor one of the most
motivational factors is when people tell
you this can't be done that starts a
fire inside the head of an inventor and
they want to show them that yes this can
be done
it's been a long and tough project but
now we have come to the point where we
have happy employees happy customers
happy consumers and most important of
all happy Salman
[Music]
[Applause]
we suffer setbacks Arion but now their
material used widely I think the
perseverance and the use of patent
information is an example for all
inventors
d throw is an almost magical material
it's soft and flexible so it can move
with you but it's instantaneously locks
together on impact to protect you and
then straight afterwards returns to its
flexible state some liquids exhibit
dilating properties such as cornstarch
and water if you move them slowly they
behave like a liquid but if you move
them quickly they behave more like a
solid the material we've based our
technology on has actually been around
for a very long time and amazingly it's
never really found a commercial
application apart from in children's
stories Daiya latent materials really
fascinated us and we knew that there was
some opportunity to invent something new
with these remarkable materials the
problem with these materials are that
they are liquid and you need some sort
of container to keep them where you want
them and we realize that instead of
trying to contain the liquid like a
bottle of water why don't we put the
water into the composition of the
material itself so not having any lab
equipment to their disposal we
immediately went back into the kitchen
and started to try and get the dilated
material to impregnate into an open cell
phone we had a really terrible moment at
one point where I was doing some more
web research on patents and I actually
discovered a Japanese patent doing
exactly what we were doing and we had to
suddenly go back to the drawing board go
back to our ideas and say how can we
solve this problem
[Music]
so we have no other option is to hunker
down to the lab and spend many hours to
try and find a solution which we did now
we finally had in our hands we refile
the patent
raised funding based upon the patent in
the product and started a successful
business journey
[Music]
[Applause]
you can learn a lot from nature in this
example biomimicry is helping us to
maintain a healthy marine ecosystem
while enabling fuel efficient shipping
nature is a big inspiration for inventor
for example look at this sea urchin it
always lives in the water and it stays
free of any kind of organisms it's
amazing
here's a completely different story
barnacles a mussel stick to the hull of
a ship it's an enormous problem for
ships
the typical solution is to use
antifouling paints but each year these
toxic paints spill 50,000 tons of
chemicals into the sea I developed the
spiny surfaces based on fibers that are
the basis for my patterns
challenge was to find the right balance
between length thickness stiffness and
density of the fibers after many test
runs it's worked quite well and I
applied for a patent immediately the
patent was key to the business
development
it helps me to have doctor on my
business card in the same way the patent
gives me credibility it shows that
there's more behind my invention than
just the crazy inventor
this rep is really a game changer and a
breakthrough for the environment itself
to use a film with fibers attached to it
it prevents bio filing without any
toxins it can easily apply to the hull
of a ship it can easily be removed as
well just use high pressure washers
without any chemicals and it can lead to
fuel savings as well people think the
smoother the surface the faster it will
go but that's not the case
the solution root for Yas as well as for
big vessels with my next invention based
on the skin of a nutter
I will further increase the fuel savings
[Music]
if I look into my heart I'm an inventor
it's not about making profits it's about
getting the product out there
and most of all it's about getting the
toxins out of the markets
[Music]
to present the award in the small and
medium-sized enterprises category I
would like to invite on stage miss will
Rica Rob McCullough chair of the jury
president Casa fsme United and
vice-president of the Austrian Federal
Chamber of Commerce
[Applause]
the European inventor award 2019 in the
category small and medium-sized
enterprises Philistines please give up
on stage big round of applause for Vic
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
bigboy heartily conceited now your
invention was based on nature on the
principle of the sea urchin principle
why do you think it took so long for
anyone to find out that this can be used
as a basis for an invention take so long
it didn't take a very long time not to
find that this principles possible but
it takes a long time for someone to
really pursue and keep on going and make
it into a product now your fiber wrap
can be applied to sea vessels but also
to static structures such as harbor
facilities or oil rigs where do you
think is the best application good
question in principle the best
application is where the most chemicals
are used so for the big vessels the big
container vessels for example they spill
the most of the chemicals into the water
so that's the best application it's not
the most logical application as well
because these companies there are less
aware of the environment so that's why
the consumer marketing at the moment is
the best best place to do it because
people are people do care and nowadays
now with this amazing impact that it can
have on sea pollution worldwide how will
you actually get it out there to the sea
vessels around the world that's the
biggest challenge I'm facing at the
moment I mean even now with only the new
before with only the nomination I'm
already getting in requests from
Australia from Canada Brazil all around
the world so that's the biggest
challenge now to develop a network to
get it out there and to get it onto the
ships mm-hmm now you you being not even
a small enterprise but a micro
enterprise is just you now how important
Micro yes may be the wrong choice of
words
but I imagine patents must have been
really important for you to keep going
yeah for sure that's one of the one of
the main I said safeguard for your
technology I mean if my competitors are
multi-billion companies yeah so when you
have two patents you're released your
safeguard and that you you your
technology is safe so that that helps a
lot yeah I mean I'm a small company the
only one person at the moment of course
I'm not doing it alone and I have a lot
of people suppliers would also former
colleagues that work together with me so
that's also a way to to work together
that's also a really good way to to get
something really really big out there
yeah now for your next invention you've
taken inspiration from another sea
animal from the sea otter do you have a
sea life encyclopedia on your bedside
table it's a combination that you mean
you look at sea you look at the animals
and see how how to perform how they look
like and then combining the results you
find in the field with your products
combine that with what other creatures
are there and then you make the analogy
with the sea otter for example in this
case yeah seems to make sense
all right thank you very much please
step over to the pictures
so requires a prime example of an agile
light investor armed with the European
patent and an amazing inspiration taken
from nature to reduce pollution in the
seas
[Music]
now ladies and gentlemen before we
arrive to the last two categories we'd
like to take a pause to catch our breath
get ready for a thrilling performance
where classicism becomes innovation
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hi my name is spike
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my name
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what a great contrast between classical
opera and innovative contemporary art
great thank you to our artists for this
amazing performance a big round of
applause
it is that time to devote our attention
to a special category the popular price
over the last six weeks the public have
been voting online for their favorite
out of all 15 finalists by voting on the
EPO website
almost 15,000 votes were cast and three
finalists in particular captured the
imagination of the public at rapping
almost 30 percent of the total vote
between them but who came out on top
well for the announcement of the popular
prize I would like to invite on stage
mr. Joseph grotto Quinn president of the
Czech industrial property of his in
chairman of the Administrative Council
of the European Patent Organization
[Applause]
[Music]
now let us remind ourselves who the 15
finalists are including three we have
not yet met the finalists of the
European inventor award 2019 are clouds
feisty and Lanford hackle
higher-performance plastic recycling
Antonio Corridor and careless fair mean
menendez concrete mold for better break
waters alexander fan delay Lee and Carol
Vandenberg milking robots for healthy
accounts Jerome Galen immuno score a
clearer cancer test Matias man protein
analysis to diagnose disease
Patrizia patella knee pleasure I said
blood filtration to detect tumor cells
urban Bayer and Gavin McIntyre
eco-friendly packaging from mushrooms
come on Joshua and the mobile IT vision
for vehicles to improve road safety
Akira Yoshino lithium-ion battery and
its evolution has been bet lasers and AI
for healthier salmon Rick Bryan marine
antifouling fiber wrap Richard Palmer
and Phillip Cree flexible armor that
hardens on impact
margaritas Salas vulgaris DNA
amplification for genomics Maximilian
Haider sharper electron microscopes
Martha kerkovich advances in video
compression
ladies and gentlemen the European
inventor award 2019 in the category
popular prize goes to
Eureka solace margherita Celesteville
gave us big round of applause the winner
of the popular prize
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
professor la Salle's en hora Buena now
the audence have not yet had the benefit
of seeing our short film about you that
will come in a minute
could you tell us briefly why is DNA
amplification important what is it good
for
well the amplification is important when
you have very small amounts of DNA tiny
amounts of DNA that you can no sequence
you cannot study then the free 2090 and
the polymerase makes millions of copies
of this of this DNA so that now you can
sequence see the studies and analyses
that was a very descriptive
I'm sure there's much more behind it now
you went to New York to work with
Spanish Nobel Prize winners severe
torture in the 1960s when you come back
to Spain you went on to establish
biochemistry center from scratch what
were the main challenges at the time
well the time was that to introduce
molecular biology in Spain that was not
assistance so my husband myself came
back and developed the molecular biology
that we had learn in several choice lab
now your invention has brought in
millions of euros to the Spanish
National Research Council how important
do you think it is for money from
revenues coming from research to go back
into funding bodies well this money is
it was very important I mean not only
for the spanish national research
council that was the owner for the
patent but also for the inventors and
also for our lab and our center so we
all benefit from this for this money
obtained from this patent right thank
you very much
a big round of applause please
for the pictures
[Applause]
Margareta cell has a Spanish national
treasure without so much to advance
biochemistry and genetic research in her
home country
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen the time has come
for our final category lifetime
achievement as this title suggests our
final trio finalists have all dedicated
their entire lives to generating not
just one or even a few patterns between
them that have been named on over 200 of
them all of them have dedicated many
years to their own particular field be
it
biochemistry electron microscopy or
video codecs all of them have been
tireless and inspirational let's meet
them our finalists for the lifetime
achievement award 2019 are from Spain
margarita phallus Salas vulgaris
from Austria Maximilian hider
and from Poland Marta kerkovich
now let's look at the three films
presenting their extraordinary lives
margarita Salas is not just a scientist
who enabled modern DNA testing
she has champions for women in science
for over five decades she's a role model
for all of us
can you listen in order to listen go has
to amplify
[Music]
if the sound is low one it's so
amplified and this just like in the case
of the DNA if one has a very small
amount of DNA for example even the
sickle molecule one needs to amplify it
in order to sequence and to study the
DNA my most important invention was the
use of the feet went in idna polymerase
for the inner amplification it is widely
used in biotechnology and in medicine
[Music]
well I feed is my business thesis I
decided to go to the York with the Nobel
prize-winner separate or where I spent
three years when we came back to Spain
my husband myself we started the
Philippine I'd work on together
after few years my husband that was very
generous and wanted me to be independent
decided to quit the free 29 and they
start at une world by himself
so that I could be independent for
defeat 29 work from that time on I just
became Marietta Salas and not my
husband's wife
when I presented a the work on the
faithful 2090 the polymerase USB asked
me whether I was worth but in the
polymerase and I said yes so they helped
me with the patent the person was very
profitable from the economic point of
view
for me rosettes is really a passion I do
not perceive life without research so I
hope to be able to keep going for many
many years from now
[Music]
a scientist we often want to explore and
understand the world that is too small
for the eye to see the ability to bring
a single atom into clear focus has
changed the path of science forever this
puzzle and microscopy was about 60 K
told to solve this we needed a better
lens using beams of Lights has its
limits and one located see small things
we use beams of electrons
for decades there was a problem the
image result from electron microscopes
about one on times worse within their
authority performance while they are the
images all to focus the bottom itself
was obvious but the solution proposed in
1948 was just a theory
you were knew how to build tonight
collector
Allen's boy little beams
this was extremely motivating for me to
take on this challenge in an old puzzle
was after midnight in June 1997 we are
working day and night because we're
running out of money and time for our
research but at fun night we chipped a
cake food got a sharp edge even down to
one point two and some about the size of
an atom
know we can really see items we can see
how they are moving and interacting with
each other
it was a tremendous moment for science
and a big moment for me
we immediately applied for a patent and
we established a company practice our
today found in 90% of all transmission
Etobicoke scopes around the world
because in sharper images and the Atomic
Age
[Music]
since the invention of motion pictures
there have been relatively few
inventions in the field of video and
television one of them is the adding of
sound to movies in the thirties the
number one is the technology of video
compression which allows us to handle an
enormous amount of video data in an
efficient manner resolutions maybe 200
by 200 pixels and very few frames per
second compresses video compression is
based on modeling the motion between
different frames and modeling the
correlation between the pixels within
the same frame
last twenty years I have been working on
almost every part of the modern video
codec contributed hundreds of methods to
improve them
finally I found my way to USA and I'm
currently working for Qualcomm this is a
company which understand long term
research
when I'm at work I'm usually analyzing
the problem but I noticed that the
solution really comes to my mind when
I'm outside
when we developed new methods and
algorithms we of course do patent them
but almost immediately we bring them to
standardization forums we want to
inspire other engineers to improve and
further because standardization forums
foster both collaboration and
competition
currently I am contributing to visa
standardization which is supposed to
finish with of next year
and provide another 35% rate reduction
over a TVC I'm especially proud to work
on the standardization because I believe
that both me and my team contributed to
launching the standardization effort
[Music]
to present the award in the lifetime
achievement category I would like to
write on stage
professor Ursula Keller winner of the
Lifetime Achievement Award last year and
member of the jury
[Music]
[Applause]
the winner in the category of lifetime
achievement is
[Music]
Marguerita Valles Caldera professor
asanas please come on stage
[Applause]
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh Travis
welcome back on stage now it's great to
know that the public and the jury agree
so let's pick up a conversation where we
left off now you were studying one
bacteriophage 529 for a very long time
why this one we were wondering whether
you're spending your time yeah we
working with faithful 20 night for over
50 years now the reason to choose the
face this face is because of its small
size so that we could develop the
molecular biology in Spain the one that
we have learned in New York with
separate Oh
so how do you see your research going in
the future to shape feels like genetics
healthcare and other fields well this is
this DNA the DNA polymerase induced by
the face when it affects the bacteria
has many many applications for as we
have said for being amplification for
genetic analysis for forensic studies
for political ideological studies so
it's really very very wealthy used very
versatile now if you're a very esteemed
and long career what were your most
memorable moments well important
findings and memory and important
memories for example when we saw the
properties of these DNA polymerase say
then we we thought well this may be used
for the interpretation so we clearly
decided to patent the the polymerization
well we think that the faithful thing
idea the Polaris is the best policy
[Laughter]
now I hope that this will also be a good
memory in the future for you thank you
very much bigger
plaws for lifetime achievement award
winner professor
Salas
[Applause]
padded on the 5:29 polymerase Verdean
amplification brought in over six
million euros for the spanish national
research council now please remain on
stage come back on stage it is time for
the official group photos very quick
for the Fisher group photo I would also
like to invite on stage the president of
the pipe and office this afternoon camp
eNOS as well as all of today's winners
with their beautiful trophies hey could
someone else to bring professor Salas
popular prize trophy on stage
[Music]
beside
[Applause]
yes don't forget your trophy
so
[Music]
big applause for the witness of the 2019
European inventor award
and a big smile
like to take this opportunity to also
express our thanks to all the presenters
all the different categories and to our
jury members and last but not least our
hosts the president of the European
Patent Office mistletoe Jakob he knows
nobody got somebody got
now prefer the capture of this special
occasion we would like to invite on
stage all of the finalists of the 2019
European events award please come up on
stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
face that way remember that these are
the very best of over 475 high-caliber
proposal submitted through the European
Patent Office last year
the congratulations again to all of you
all our finalists and winners of 2019
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen we have come to the
end of the 2019 European inventor award
ceremony we have seen great inventions
and we have met inspirational men and
women behind these inventions so we hope
to see most of you next year again thank
you again everyone and congratulations
to all of you watching this broadcast we
hope that you have enjoyed it as much as
we have here in Vienna thank you and
goodbye
and finally ladies and gentlemen we have
all cordially invited to join us for
lunch outside in the fire
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you